حديث الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تحول
مؤخرا مشاهدينا الى داخل الروسي بعدما
اشتدت الهجمات على المنطقه الحدوديه في
بيلجرود فبعد هجمات وتوغل للقوات
الاوكرانيه في العمق الروسي بحسب موسكو
استمر القصف على المنطقه خلال الليل وحتى
صباح اليوم حاكم بالقرود صرح ان الحرائق
اندلعت في بلده شابكينو اسراء قصف القوات
الاوكرانيه لوسط البلده ضربات ادت الى
وقوع خسائر في صفوف المدنيين بحسب حاكم
المنطقه مؤكدا تضرر البنيه التحتيه
والسكنيه في ثلاث في ثلاث مناطق حدوديه
اخرى
[موسيقى]
بعد ان تحولت بالقرود الى منطقه ساخنه دخل
الرعب الى الحياه اليوميه لسكان المنطقه
لتتحول المدينه الى مدينه الاشباح صحيفه
نيورتانز الامريكيه قالت ان بالقرود تشهد
عمليات اجلاء للسكان خاصه مع تحول التشيبي
كينو الى خط مواجهه جديد حاكم الاقليم
افاد باجلاء اكثر من 2500 شخص من السكان
ونقلهم الى ملاجئ مؤقته بعيدا عن المنطقه
الحدوديه بالاضافه الى الاف الفرين حسب
شهادات ادلبها سكان المنطقه
[موسيقى]
احس القرى وخصوصا منطقه شبكيينو التي
تعرضت للقصف على الاستماع لموقف السلطات
والمغادره مؤقتا من منازلهم من اجل الحفاظ
على اهم شيء وهو حياتهم وحياه المقربين
منهم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات